[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue sur tv soixante dix
huit pour l'entretien politique chaque
semaine nous allons à la rencontre des
maires des yvelines aujourd'hui geoffroy
backs de keating est avec nous bonjour
bonjour mr du perray-en-yvelines commune
de 7000 habitants située à quatre
kilomètres de rambouillet communaux vous
est d'ailleurs né tout jeune mère à 25
ans cela fait de vous le plus jeunes
maires d'île de france
élu pour la première fois donc cette
année en 2020 tout d'abord pour
commencer est ce que c'était étiquette
de jeunes mères que vous avez pendant
toute la campagne des municipales vous
colle encore un peu aujourd'hui à la
peau est ce qu'on vous en parle encore
dans les échanges que ce soit avec les
administrés ou avec les élus oui on en
parle dans le plutôt positive pour
maintenant c'est à dire que ce qui était
au début un frein une barrière de la
jeunesse est aujourd'hui devenu un
avantage pour un certain nombre
d'habitants et c'est un peu comme ça que
je le ressens c'est souligner le
dynamisme on dit que finalement bon
c'est pas mal d'avoir passé la main à la
jeunesse et donc voilà s'efforce d'être
d'être au plus proche des habitants au
quotidien et nous le rend bien
vous avez été élue en juillet dernier
victoire face à la maire divers gauche
paul est deschamps qui elle était en
poste depuis 1999 pendant ces quatre
cinq premiers mois quelles ont été vos
priorités qu'elle a été sinon votre
priorité même alors les priorités je
crois qu'il y en a beaucoup en même
temps il ya eu d'abord la crise
sanitaire évidemment qui est très
rapidement revenu donc ont annoncé les
forces et d'être le plus présent auprès
des habitants on a fait beaucoup
d'actions par rapport à cette crise
sanitaire
bien évidemment le tout la reprise en
main d'une collectivité la gestion
administrative la gestion des ressources
humaines
alors c'est sûr sa part assez parce
qu'il ya de plus concret les indignes
des habitants mais c'est la réalité
quand vous arrivez mais qui pris là une
petite centaine d'agents qui travaille à
la mairie et dont vous avez besoin de
créer le lien avec eux de remettre
trouver une gestion avec eux une
coordination donc principalement spinosi
vous occupez et puis aussi de la mise en
oeuvre des grands projets comme on
souhaite mettre en oeuvre durant ce
mandat et donc il faut amorcer très vite
si on veut les voir se concrétiser
durant cependant l'environnement faisait
partie de vos priorités pendant la
campagne
concrètement ça va se traduire comme en
maintenant dans les actes alors la
première première action on préserve les
cadres de lits préserver notre
environnement je pense que c'est la
première des actions écologiques
je vous l'avais déjà expliquer l'arrêt
du projet de la perche omar 450
logements qui devait se construire sur 7
hectares d'espacés boisés
alors on est en discussions aujourd'hui
avec le constructeur pour l'arrêter
totalement et donc ça passe par une
phase de négociation évidemment donc ça
c'est la première de nos actions déjà
protégés 7 hectares d'espacés boisés et
puis évidemment il ya un certain nombre
d'actions que l'on souhaite mettre en
place
l'approvisionnement de nos cantines en
produits locaux bio et circuits courts
on a déjà mis en place un nouveau marché
pour la cantine donc on a fortement
augmenté la part de bio dans les
produits qui sont dans les cantines
donc c'est pour la tournée que la phase
on a mis en place le marché
on n'a pas encore attribué le marché
mais voilà déjà d'ores et déjà en
augmenter la demande supprimer le
plastique à usage unique dans les
cantines
on est en train de travailler sur la
performance énergétique des bâtiments et
aux quelqu'un on répondrait un appel à
prendre appel à projets de l'état et
puis on a un certain nombre d'actions
comme favoriser la pratique du vélo donc
on en a mais on a un diagnostic sur sur
schéma vélo dans la commune et on est en
train de regarder comment le mettre en
place désormais on va parler aussi de
vos autres projets de l'avenir de cette
commune peut être un mot sur le contexte
sur l'actualité aussi entre la crise
économique la crise sanitaire
concrétisation au site cette disparition
de la taxe d'habitation qui va aussi
agité un petit peu les différents
conseils municipaux des communes en ce
début d'année
vous êtes inquiet pour les finances de
la commune et sur la mise en place de
certains projets alors on est inquiet
oui et non heureusement on est encore en
quelques mois encore des marges de
manoeuvre sur la situation financière de
la commune
on a
assurer aux habitants qu'on ferait un
mandat sans augmentation d'impôts donc
ça passe par la sobriété dans les
investissements de la commune
on a déjà étalé un peu tout didier pour
regarder où étaient les marges de
manoeuvre sur le fonctionnement
notamment donc sur les fonctions support
de la commune ils permettront dégager
des marges de manoeuvre sur
l'investissement on sait qu'on va faire
appel beaucoup à des subventions
notamment régionaux départementaux pour
accompagner nos investissements et puis
c'est sûr qu évidemment quand vous
arrivez vous trouvez une situation qui
n'est pas qui n'est pas ce qui était
dépeint par la précédente municipalité
il ya eu de la gabegie financière bien
évidemment il ya eu des des finances
qu'on était un peu caché notamment sur
la scène du sport je rappelle que la
municipalité précédente avait intégré le
budget à ses fins de la commune dans le
budget communal chose que normalement
nous ne faisons pas la compétence à 6
francs a été dé transférer à la
communauté d'agglomération
donc ça a été aussi un débat qui a eu
avec que la police d'agglomération
donc voilà ça c'est un certain nombre de
sujets comme ça mais voilà où je compte
bien tenir notre engagement et toute mon
équipe
aussi nous tenons notre engagement on
souhaite ne pas augmenter les impôts de
toute la mandature
parmi vos différents engagements il y
avait aussi de la volonté de faire
revenir aussi est de faire venir tout
simplement ces entreprises aussi sur une
commune de 7000 habitants c'est
quelquefois un peu plus compliqué de ne
pas devenir une ville dortoir justement
comment vous allez réussir à faire venir
ces entreprises maintenant concrètement
sachant que là aussi le contexte est
compliqué alors le contexte est très
compliqué ça c'est évident aujourd'hui
l'action sur l'économie c'est
principalement de maintenir ce que l'on
à maintenir nos commerces accompagner
nos entreprises les informer les aides
auxquelles ils ont droit
sinon évidemment dans le long terme
l'objectif c'est évidemment de
redynamiser la commune ont redonné de
l'attractivité à cette commune dont l'un
d'eux voulait évidemment les commerces
donc je pense pas qu'on essaye de donner
une nouvelle image opéré on a fait un
certain nombre d'événements qui ont
attiré beaucoup beaucoup d'habitants et
aux alentours notamment avec les marchés
nocturnes il en a fait un village
noël surtout les mois de décembre qui
fonctionne très bien et beaucoup
d'animations donc ça ça redonne de
l'attractivité directement à la commune
et ça fait rayonner autour et donc ça
donne évidemment envie de vous faire
consommer localement consommer opérer
maintenant sur le volet entreprise il ya
évidemment tout un travail aujourd'hui
là le but plus de d'attirer les
entreprises sur cette période là
actuelle en a qui nous empêche de voir
comme ça à long terme on est
principalement en train d'accompagner
les entreprises au quotidien les
conseillers pour quelle heure qu'elle
arrive en tout cas à répondre à des
crises sanitaires
et puis en parallèle on est en train de
travailler évidemment pour étendre donne
industrielle la zone industrielle du
chemin vert pour attirer de nouvelles
entreprises sur les mois et les années
qui viennent
ça se passe dans un travail avec
l'agglomération aussi vous dépendez de
l'agglomération de rambouillet
territoire comment se passent les
échanges justement avec cette
agglomération très bien ça se passe très
très bien et moi je siège en tout cas la
commission au développement économique
de la communauté d'agglomération donc ça
se passe très bien j'ai des échanges
très de très bons échanges avec le
président de la communauté
d'agglomération thomas bourg landes
je suis vice président à la communauté
d'agglomération donc je fait pleinement
partie de la gestion de la communauté
d'agglomération justement 2010 est juste
pour revenir un petit pas en arrière là
la commune aurait pu faire le choix
d'une autre intercommunalité à ce moment
là en 2017 vous étiez plutôt avec
coignard et maurepas qui ont fait le
choix de réintégrer saint quentin en
yvelines vous ce choix qui a été fait en
2010 est pour vous c'est le meilleur
restait rambouillet territoire c'est la
solution la mieux alors je rentrerai pas
dans ce débat parce que c'est un débat
qui est un peu compliqué mais je pense
en tout cas que le père et est forte
pour tourner aussi vers rambouillet le
territoire en fait à la mi chemin donc
il y avait pas y'a pas de bonne réponse
pour une commode qui à la fois tourné
vers
la communauté de saint quentin en
yvelines et à la fois tourné vers
rambouillet je pense ceci dit qu'on est
quand même sur un cadre de vie une
typologie de communes qui est très
proche et qui est très similaire à aux
autres communes de rambouillet
territoire et donc les aspirations les
attentes des habitants sur le cadre de
vie sont très proches et pour moi
évidemment nous avons tout notre
dernière question l'année prochaine 2021
il y aura des élections départementales
régionales ce sera au mois de juin
est ce que vous serez engagé est ce que
vous serez vous-même en campagne
candidats se soient sur la liste aux
régionales nuit sur les départementales
peut-être alors la question se pose pas
actuellement au sommet on est très très
impliqué aujourd'hui sur la gestion de
la crise sanitaire
on est sur les six premiers mois du
mandat on donne énormément ne compte pas
nos heures
et puis de toute façon on ne sait même
pas quand ce sont les élections on ne
sait pas quelle est la date la question
ne se pose on viendra vous le moment
venu pour voir cela en tout cas merci
beaucoup joffard backs de keating mère
du perray-en-yvelines d'avoir été avec
nous pour cet entretien politique
l'émission revient bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]
non